President Vladimir
Putin is accusing the Wagner
mercenary group of an armed rebellion.
And he warns that those involved
will be punished.
The head of the volunteer
group Yevgeny
Prigozhin,
says his forces have taken control of
excuse me,
Russian military facilities
in the region of Rostov on Don.
He threatens to move on to Moscow
so if Russia's top general
and defense minister don't meet him
you should ask him.
This would be open again.
We came here.
We want to receive
the chief of general staff.
And so we go
until they aren't here
and so they aren't here.
We will be located here
blockading the city of Rostov
and will go to Moscow.
President Putin calls
the actions
by Prigozhin
a betrayal
and a stab in the back
to the Russian people.
And he says those who follow him
will pay the price
for all those who deliberately
chose the path of treachery,
who prepared
an armed mutiny,
who chose the path of blackmail
and terrorist methods.
Will face inevitable punishment.
And we'll answer both to the law
and to our people.
We're following all of the developments
on what's happening in Russia
with our reporters and analysts
around the world this morning.
So let's start there
with the latest
on what's happening in Russia right now.
CNN chief
international security
correspondent Nick
Paton Walsh is
tracking the developments for us.
What is happening right now
We've never seen anything like this
in Putin's Russia before.
Quite unprecedented territory,
a direct threat
to his grip on power for 23 years.
Now, at this stage,
we are checking to see
if the Wagner forces you heard about
that are in Rostov, seen on the streets.
They're casually relaxed around
key buildings.
Remember, this is a military hub
for the Russian war
in Ukraine
and forces across that southern region
to see if these forces
are indeed
trying to move, as they say,
they are in the direction of Moscow.
There are suggestions
from some of their supporters
that they may
have got into the city of Orange,
kind of half way on the highway up
towards Moscow. That is not confirmed.
And indeed denied
by Kremlin backed officials in that area.
But at the same time, too,
the governor of Orange has said
that combat measures
by the Russian military
have indeed begun.
That would be a suggestion
that the Russian military
are indeed taking on Volga now.
Now, it's unclear
the size of the bargaining force
that has moved,
but this all began on Friday
with an extraordinary series
of statements
by their leader, Yevgeny
Prigozhin, essentially
taking issue with the entire cause
of Russia's war in Ukraine.
Saying that essentially Russians
had been deceived
and there wasn't a threat from NATO's.
Russians were not being persecuted.
That was suddenly,
it seemed, responded to by a claims
of an airstrike against a park in a camp
probably inside of Ukraine.
That's been denied
by the Russian Ministry of Defense,
but has put into place
this extraordinary
series of events of volcanic forces,
it seems, being taken from Ukraine
and marching on a Russian military
hub, Rostov on Don.
And now it seems heading further.
And the important thing to note
here is while perhaps Yevgeny
progression may have begun,
all of this
as a bid to take on the top brass
of Russia's military,
the defense minister Sergei Shoigu,
and some of the chief of staff
now running that operation.
It's now
clearly him against Vladimir Putin.
He's been utterly clear
in his most recent statement
that he thinks the president is mistaken
to suggest this is a betrayal.
And Putin was very clear
that those who are now behind
this insurrection have chosen
the path of blackmail.
And terrorist methods
and will face inevitable punishment.
A suggestion in that speech from Putin,
if you want to lay your arms down,
there might be some sucker.
But frankly, straight up here,
he was saying,
we're going to put this down.
The question is, can he
and how long does this go on for?
Every hour,
essentially calls into question
Putin's control of Russia
and more importantly, possibly,
too, for the world,
quite how the war in Ukraine
will play out in the hours ahead.
Yeah, Nick, authoritarianism
or if this is now progressed
a totalitarian
totalitarianism does not allow
for this type of confrontation either
rhetorically or militarily.
So what potentially is next?
Are we talking potential civil war?
You say this is now prigozhin v Putin.
Is this a coup attempt?
How would you frame this
Look, this has become
prigozhin versus Putin.
There's no doubt about it.
After speech,
we heard from Putin
and the response from Prigozhin.
I think it would be naive, frankly,
for what goes into
to think he could do something like this
and will essentially echo
the wrath of the Kremlin head
and have that taken out
instead on the top
brass of Russia's military.
Where do we go from now?
Well, it comes down to really
how much of Russia's
beleaguered military,
the special forces
decimated after this
ghastly war in Ukraine,
where the frankly, mismanagement
has been in evidence
from the very first days,
was supposed to take three days.
Now, here we are
six months in
and they're still laboring
to try and hold parts of territory.
It depends
what's left of the Russian
military to defend Putin.
Do the Special Forces
of the FSB, Russia's
security services, feel
they want to turn their guns on Prigozhin
and the men around him of fighters
who've lost thousands of colleagues
in the fight for Baku
to put themselves up
as the storied heroes
that brutal fighters,
make no mistake about it.
But the storied heroes of Russia's
frontline activity
are the Russian military willing
to turn their guns upon them,
or are we going to see Vadim
as it moves,
amassing more strength
from Russia's military
as it heads towards Moscow?
I can't believe,
frankly, I'm even saying
this unprecedented territory.
And I think it goes to show
when you get behind the curtain
of exactly what's happening in Putin's
Russia, about which we know
so little finally,
when sunlight shines upon it,
it is an utterly startling
picture of betrayal
we're seeing here and utter chaos
and a man at the top
who's clearly not in control.
Yeah, an extraordinary
turn of events and a big question
as to what this means for Putin
and the future of Russia.
Nick Paton Walsh, thank you very much.
Just go now to CNN's
senior international correspondent
Frederik Pleitgen.
Fred,
tell us more about Yevgeny
Prigozhin, who rose to prominence
as a close ally of Vladimir Putin for
for many, many years.
He was one of his wealthy oligarchs
and then turned into
this very effective leader
of a private military group.
And now he's challenging
Putin's grip on power
as the leader of of a whole empire,
if you will, Amara.
It really is a rise
that is also unprecedented inside Russia,
but certainly one that also speaks
to how Vladimir Putin controls
the country.
We have to keep in mind that Yevgeny
Prigozhin
is still known to many people
as being Putin's caterer.
Or Putin's chef
because he ran a catering service
that apparently also catered
to Vladimir Putin as well,
and then became closer
and closer to the Russian president
and started
building this big empire,
which, of course, also includes
propaganda institutions.
The Internet Research Agency, of course,
which is known for having meddled
the U.S.
says in the 2016 election
Yevgeny
Prigozhin is one of the individuals
who was sanctioned by the U.S.
for meddling in the 2016 election.
But he then built that empire
including the Viognier private
military company.
He is of course
the head of the Wagner
private military company.
And it's one of those things
where we've seen that
that company rise meteoric.
Lee really over the past couple of years
I was in Syria in I think 2014 or 2015.
When we first saw Wagner
appear on the scene there,
they were essentially doing
base protection,
some of the things that
private military companies do,
but then continuously got involved
in the fight as well.
He then branched out
into the oil business
for the oil fields
that the Assad regime
had taken back,
essentially taking control of those,
getting a cut of that as well,
and then moved operations
also into Africa and built
an empire there,
training African forces,
for instance,
with his private military company.
But then also,
of course, getting into the gold
diamond trade as well, running mines
and the like.
So he certainly became
a force
globally and someone
whose global reach continued.
And then if we look at Ukraine,
that is where I would say this turned
from being a private military company
that does security
and maybe some training
into what we see now,
which is a full fledged army.
In fact,
Yevgeny Prigozhin himself calls Wagner
the most powerful army in Russia.
He calls it
one of the most powerful armies
in the world, quite frankly.
And a lot of what Nick
was talking about before
certainly was a catalyst for that,
which is the battle of Bermuda,
which was obviously extremely brutal,
where he started using these tactics
of taking prisoners from Russian prisons
and then bringing them to the front lines
to charge at Russian positions.
I was in a bad mood
for when some of that was going on.
And we had Ukrainians who were telling us
that there were just
dozens and dozens
of volunteer mercenaries
who kept charging their positions
all the time.
And it was very difficult
for them to hold the line.
However, he's claims
that he had success in Bakhmut
and he rubbed that in the face
of the defense ministry,
obviously claiming
that he was better
than the defense minister.
And now we see that full on feud
out in the open.